se trata de las primeras reglas
generales en el mundo para regular los
sistemas de Inteligencia artificial los
diputados del parlamento europeo dieron
el primer paso por un lado buscan
fomentar la innovación y por el otro
frenar los peligros potenciales de la
tecnología las normas de la ley de
Inteligencia artificial de la Unión
Europea cobraron mayor urgencia con la
aparición de sadd por el temor de que
genere una mayor desinformación que
afecte la democracia la ley de
Inteligencia artificial de la Unión
Europea Busca regular cualquier producto
o servicio que utiliza la Inteligencia
artificial clasifica el riesgo del
sistema de Inteligencia artificial de
mínimo a inaceptable las infracciones
generarían multas de hasta 30 millones
de euros o el 6% de los ingresos
globales anuales de una empresa en el
caso de gigantes tecnológicos como
Google y Microsoft las multas podrían
ascender a millones de millones entre
las disposiciones de la ley para
mantener la Inteligencia artificial bajo
control habría una prohibición de los
sistemas que utilizan la vigilancia
biométrica el reconocimiento de
emociones y la vigilancia predictiva
para identificar posibles actividades
delictivas la legislación de la Unión
Europea sobre esta tecnología podría
tardar años en entrar en vigor por
completo para llenar el vacío Europa y
Estados Unidos están redactando un
código de conducta voluntario la ONU
también propone uno tras advertir de
graves consecuencias si no se toman
medidas
la proliferación del odio y las mentiras
en el espacio digital está causando
graves daños a nivel mundial ahora
está alimentando el conflicto la muerte
y la destrucción está amenazando la
democracia y los Derechos Humanos
Mientras tanto Reino Unido aspira a
ocupar un puesto de liderazgo en
Inteligencia artificial por lo que será
el anfitrión de una Cumbre mundial sobre
seguridad de la Inteligencia artificial
en la segunda mitad del año en medio de
preocupaciones de que las reglas y
regulaciones podrían ser pocas y tardías
para controlar el poder de la tecnología